We are going to start with the
lecture notes from last Friday
because I didn't finish them.
What we were doing at the end
of lecture last time was
probably some of the hardest
concepts that we've covered so
far in this course,
and maybe even in the whole
course.
And you will remember that we
finally got around to talking
about what does a wave function
mean, and how does it actually
represent the electron in our
hydrogen atom.
And we saw that the physically
significant interpretation of
the wave function was not
actually the wave function
itself, but the wave function
squared.
So psi here,
which we learned,
has to be labeled by three
quantum numbers,
n, l and m.
And that is a function of three
position variables,
r, theta and phi.
If you square that,
the physical interpretation of
that is a probability density.
This means this has units.
This has units of inverse
volume.
It's a probability per unit
That is very important.
It's not a probability,
but a probability per unit
volume.
But the other quantity that we
would like to know something
about is a probability.
We would like to know something
about how far is the electron
from the nucleus.
And, in order to do that,
we needed to invoke this
concept here,
this radial probability
distribution function.
And what we said it was last
time is a probability of finding
an electron in a spherical shell
of radius r, and that spherical
shell has a thickness dr.
Or, another way to say it is
that it's the probability of
finding the electron at a
distance between r to r plus dr.
This is a probability here.
And we illustrated that in the
following way.
This gray portion here,
well, that was our dot density
diagram.
That gray portion was the
probability density,
psi squared.
In this particular case,
the (1, 0, 0) wave function,
the 1s wave function,
we squared it.
And then we represented the
magnitude of that by that dot
density diagram or the density
of the dots where that was
highest.
That represented the highest
value of psi squared.
And then it radially
dissipated, exponentially.
That is what that gray dot
density diagram was.
And now, if we take a spherical
shell and we put it right at the
origin where our nucleus is,
and that spherical shell has a
radius r, and since it is a
shell, it is infinitesimally
thin, it has a thickness dr
here, the probability of finding
the electron in that spherical
shell is what the radial
probability is.
So it's going to be able to
tell us how far,
or the probability of finding
the electron between r and r
plus dr.
Now, how do we calculate the
radial probability distribution,
or how do we calculate the
radial probability?
Well, the first thing you have
to realize is what the volume of
this spherical shell is.
The volume of this spherical
shell is just the surface area
of the sphere,
4 pi r squared,
times the thickness dr.
That's the
volume of the spherical shell.
Now, what can I do to calculate
the radial probability?
Well, we know that psi squared
is the probability density,
probability per unit volume.
If I multiply it by that unit
volume, in this case 4 pi r
squared dr,
the volumes here cancel and we
have a probability.
That's our radial probability.
And this is strictly correct
for s-orbitals only.
There is a little difference
here for the p-orbitals and
d-orbitals.
We're actually not going to do
that, but this is our radial
probability.
Let's take an example.
Let's look at an example of the
radial probability for the 1s
state.
What have we done here to
calculate radial probability?
We've taken psi squared.
We've squared 1s wave function
and have multiplied it by 4 pi r
squared dr for all these values
of r.
We've calculated psi at all the
values of r and multiplied it by
4 pi r squared dr.
And the result is this radial
probability.
That's what I'm plotting right
here.
What do you see?
Well, the first thing you see
is that the electron,
the most probable value of r,
or the most probable distance
of the electron from the
nucleus, is quite a ways out.
That most probable value is all
the way out here,
where r is equal to a nought.
And I said last time that this
a nought is a constant.
It's called the Bohr radius.
And today I will explain why it
is called the Bohr radius.
It has a value of 0.529
angstroms.
So it is most likely to find
the electron about a half an
angstrom away from the nucleus.
The most probable value,
or the most probable position
of finding the electron is not
at the nucleus.
And, in fact,
look at this,
that radial probability here is
actually zero at r equals zero.
That seems a little strange
because we looked at the
probability density.
Remember we plotted the
probability density the last
time which was just psi squared
for the (1,0,0) wave function as
a function of r.
And, when we did that,
we saw that at r equals zero
here, the probability density
was some large maximum value and
that this exponentially decayed.
Well, the probability density
is a large maximum value at r
equals zero, but when we look at
the radial probability,
it's zero at r equals zero.
Why?
Well, because when we go to
calculate the radial probability
we are multiplying that
probability density by a sphere,
a sphere whose volume now has
shrunk to zero because r is
equal to zero.
So the probability of finding
that electron right at the
nucleus between r equals zero
and r plus dr is zero.
So the most likely distance of
that electron and the hydrogen
atom from the nucleus is one
Bohr radius.
Actually, then the diameter of
that hydrogen atom we typically
say is twice the Bohr radius or
a little bit over an angstrom.
So that's what a radial
probability distribution
function means.
It's going to tell us the
probability of finding the
electron a certain distance r to
r plus dr from the nucleus.
All right.
Now I want to explain to you
where this a nought comes
from.
And that allows me then to also
explain a very important concept
here about quantum mechanics.
By 1911, both the electron and
the nucleus had been discovered
and scientists were trying very
hard to understand how the
electron and the nucleus hung
together.
And it wasn't really until
1926, when Schrödinger wrote
down his wave equation,
that things really began to
make sense.
But there were many attempts in
between 1911 and 1926 to
understand what was going on
with the hydrogen atom.
And one of those attempts was
made by Niels Bohr.
And what Bohr said was well,
I know this classical physics
predicts that this electron will
plummet into the nucleus in
10^-10 seconds.
That is, if I take a planetary
model, I put the nucleus in the
center and I give the electron a
uniform circular orbit around
that nucleus,
well, I know classical physics
tells me this won't hang
together.
But let me ignore that and let
me propose that there is
something quantized about the
hydrogen atom.
And he knew that because he
knew the hydrogen atom spectrum.
He knew that in the hydrogen
atom spectrum that light was
emitted at only certain
frequencies, as we saw the other
day.
And that gave him the idea that
there is something quantized
about the hydrogen atom.
So he then proposed,
let me go and I'm going to
quantize the angular momentum of
that electron going around in
this circular orbit.
So what he did was he kind of
took a classical model and he
pasted some quantum mechanical
ideas onto the system.
And when he did that the value
for r here, at which the
electron was going around the
nucleus, well,
that value of r ended up being
what we call here the Bohr
radius now, this value of a
nought.
Now, we're not going to study
the Bohr atom because it's
wrong.
And, in particular,
what it gets wrong is the
radial probability distribution.
Here is the radial probability
distribution function as it
comes out of solving the
Schrödinger equation for an
electron in this 1s state.
But here is the radial
probability distribution
function for what's called the
Bohr atom.
The radial probability,
I will just write it as RPD.
The RPD here is going to be a
whopping one right at r equals a
nought.
That's the radial probability
distribution for the Bohr atom.
What that tells us is we know
exactly where the electron is.
What that tells us is that we
know exactly that the radius of
that electron in that circular
orbit is a nought.
This is what we call a
deterministic picture.
That is we know exactly where
the electron is in terms of its
radius.
However, we now know that
what's really going on is that
we don't know exactly where the
electron is.
We cannot tell you exactly what
the radius is.
The best we can tell you is a
probability of finding the
electron within some value r to
r plus dr.
Quantum mechanics,
this is a quantum mechanical
result, is non-deterministic.
We are limited in the precision
with which we can tell you where
something is like the electron.
We're limited within the
uncertainty principle.
The uncertainty principle is
not something that we're going
to be discussing here,
but the uncertainty principle
does give us a limit to which we
can know the position and the
momentum, say,
of a particle.
So that's really the big point
here, is that quantum mechanics,
the best it can do for you is
to give you a probability of
finding the electron at some
position.
Classical mechanics,
which was really this Bohr atom
approach, will tell you exactly
where something is,
but not in quantum mechanics.
A very important difference
here.
Questions?
Yes?
Well, it does turn out that if
you go to take this distribution
function and you actually look
at the value of r,
at which this is a maximum,
it comes out to be exactly that
number, a nought.
There actually is more to the
story in the sense that that is
an accident of the particular
form of the Coulomb potential
that Bohr was able to get this
value a nought.
So this value really is a
nought, that most probable
value.
And so you saw we wrote all of
our wave functions in terms of
that constant a nought.
So certainly Bohr made a
contribution.
He realized there's something
quantized about the hydrogen
atom.
But, in order to get that,
he kind of pasted the idea of
quantization on a classical
model.
In contrast,
in Schrödinger's equation,
when we solve it,
we talked about how when you
have a differential equation you
have to apply boundary
conditions to the problem.
Well, when you apply the
appropriate boundary conditions
the quantum numbers drop out.
You're not doing an ad hoc kind
of pasting of quantization ideas
onto some model.
Other questions?
All right.
So that's the radial
probability distribution
function for the 1s wave
function.
But we would also like to look
at the radial probability
distribution function for the
other s wave functions that
we've looked at so far.
And let me go over here.
The next one we're going to
look at is for the 2s wave
function.
This will be the radial
probability distribution
function for the 2s wave
function.
This is versus r.
And, if I plot it,
what I am going to see is
something that looks like this.
Lo and behold,
the most probable value here of
r, r(mp).
This most probable value,
let me get my chalk,
is actually 6 a nought.
It is most likely for the
electron in a 2s state to be six
times as far from the nucleus as
it is in the 1s state.
That is what the radial
probability distribution
function tells us.
So if you have a hydrogen atom
that is in the first excited
state, that hydrogen atom,
in a sense, is bigger.
It's bigger in the sense that
it is more likely to find the
electron a further distance from
the nucleus than it is in the n
equals 1 state.
The other interesting thing
here about this radial
probability distribution is that
you can see where the radial
node is.
We talked about the radial node
last time.
This is r equals 2 a nought.
A radial node is the value of r
that will make your wave
function be equal to zero.
So that's the radial node.
Now, very important here.
This r equals 0 is not a radial
node.
r equals 0 is never a radial
This gets students into
trouble, so let me emphasize
this over and over again.
r equals 0 is never a radial
node.
This r equals 0 right here is a
consequence of our definition of
the radial probability 4 pi r
squared psi squared dr.
That is
not a radial node.
What about the 3s wave
function?
Let's look at that.
This is the radial probability
distribution for the 3s wave
function.
What that distribution would
look like is something like
this.
Look at where the most probable
value of r is here.
This most probable value is
11.468 a nought. It's
about 11.5 times as far out from
the nucleus as it was in the
case of the hydrogen 1s state.
So if you have a hydrogen atom
in the second excited state,
in a sense, again,
it is bigger.
It is bigger in the sense that
it is more likely to find the
electron at a larger distance
from the nucleus.
And, again, the radial
probability distribution
function reflects the two radial
nodes in the 3s wave function.
There is a node here at r
equals 1.9 a nought.
And there is a node here at r
equals 7.1 a nought.
The two radial nodes for 3s.
And there is no radial node
here at r equals 0.
This is really important.
Now, if you look at this,
it is very tempting to look at
this radial probability
distribution function and say
the following.
Well, if the electron has some
probability of being over here
and then it has some probability
of being over here,
and then it has some
probability of being over here,
then how does the electron get
from here to here to here if
this point right here at r
equals 1.9 a nought
and r equal 7.1 a nought--
How does it get there if these
points, the probability is zero?
Well, you say maybe the
probability is just small,
it's not zero.
But I am telling you that
probability is zero,
zip, zilch, nada,
nix, cipher,
nought, goose egg.
Anybody else got another one?
[LAUGHTER] It is zero.
It is not small.
It is just zero.
That is an interesting
question.
And the answer to that question
is that it's not an appropriate
question.
It's not appropriate,
because when you ask how does a
particle get from one place to
another place to another place,
what you're asking about is the
trajectory of a particle.
You're asking for a path.
How does it get from here to
here to here to here?
That's a classical idea.
And this is not a classical
system, so that's why the
question isn't appropriate.
Instead, what we have to think
about this is as a wave.
The electron is represented by
a wave.
And you know that a wave can
have amplitude at many values of
x or at many distances.
It can have amplitude,
and it does right here,
at the same time that it has
amplitude here,
amplitude there.
That's the answer to that
question.
You have to look at this
electron as a way that can have
amplitude at many different
positions simultaneously.
I know that seems strange to
you.
But this is a different world.
This is a world that you don't
have everyday experience with.
That's why it seems strange.
But it is part of our world.
It's just the world that you've
got to do some experiments to
actually see.
Yes?
What I am talking about here,
and I didn't emphasize,
I'm talking about something
called a standing wave.
You are thinking about a
traveling wave.
One thing I think I forgot to
tell you the last time is that
the wave function is,
in general, a function of r,
theta, phi, and time.
But what I forgot to tell you
is that we were not going to
look at the time dependence of
these waves.
And the reason is because we're
going to be looking at a
hydrogen atom that isn't
undergoing any chemical
reaction.
So the electron of the hydrogen
atom is bound to the nucleus.
And it stays there,
in a sense.
It is stable.
We're not going to be looking
at the wave function as two
hydrogen atoms come together and
make a hydrogen molecule.
Then, if we were doing that,
we'd have to invoke the time
dependence.
But because we're going to
start here by looking at a
hydrogen atom,
helium atom,
etc., an isolated stable atom,
there is no time dependence
here.
So we're actually looking at
something called stationary
waves.
And that has no time dependence
in it.
So this is called
time-independent or stationary
wave of quantum mechanics,
time-independent quantum
mechanics.
There is time-dependent quantum
That's a very good question.
And it doesn't choose to stay
in the 3s state very long.
That is an unstable state.
In other words,
if we put the electron in that
3s state, and we have to put
energy to do that,
that electron does want to be
in the more stable state,
which is the 1s state.
And there will be a probability
of that electron dropping down
to the 1s state and emitting in
a photon.
Just like we saw in the
hydrogen atom discharge
experiment.
We put those hydrogen atoms
into these excited states.
They didn't stay there very
long.
They dropped down,
and when they did so they
emitted a photon.
And there is some natural
probability of that happening.
In the case of the hydrogen
atom, those lifetimes,
depending on what state you're
in --
If it's a very high Rydberg,
they have long lifetimes,
but for 3s or something,
maybe 10^-10 seconds,
10^-11 seconds,
it doesn't last there very
long.
It does emit.
It does come down.
It doesn't want to be there for
a very long time.
And what that probability is
has to do with the overlap of
the wave functions between the
initial and the final state,
which isn't something that
we're going to do.
But well understood.
Now it's actually time to look
at the p-orbitals.
With the s-orbitals we saw they
were spherically symmetric.
And we used those s-orbitals to
illustrate a lot of concepts,
what we meant by a wave
function, what we meant by
probability density,
what we meant by radial
probability.
But now, we're going to look at
the 2p wave functions.
And the p wave functions,
as you probably already know,
are not spherically symmetric.
We're going to use this dot
density diagram again to
represent the probability
density for the p wave
functions.
And so I am going to take the
psi(2, 1, 0) wave function,
and I am going to square it to
get the probability density.
And then I am going to plot the
result of that in three
dimensions.
And the result is what I show
you here.
And, of course,
this is the typical pz-orbital
that you've all seen before.
And what you see,
in the case of the pz state or
the pz wave function,
is that the probability density
is symmetric around this z-axis
here.
Most of that probability
density is concentrated along
the z-axis.
And, if you look very
carefully, you can sort of see
that there is no probability
density here in this x,y-plane.
Here is the px-orbital.
I am plotting the probability
density.
That probability density is
concentrated along the x-axis.
It's symmetric along the
x-axis.
And, if you look very
carefully, you can see that
there is no probability density
in the y,z-plane.
And then the py-orbital,
that probability density is
concentrated along the y-axis.
If you look very carefully,
there is no probability density
here in the x,z-plane.
And the other thing I just
wanted to note,
you see I got this plus sign
here and the minus sign there,
plus sign there and the minus
sign there, that we talked about
the other day just very briefly.
That just indicates the sign of
the amplitude of the wave
function.
Not the wave function squared,
but the wave function itself.
Remember, sometimes it is
called the phase.
In this part here,
below this x,y-plane,
the wave function actually has
a negative value.
In this part the wave function
has a positive value.
And I said that the sign of the
wave function was going to be
important, because when we start
to make bonds,
whether you have two wave
functions that are overlapping
and they have a positive
amplitude, well,
then you have constructive
interference.
When you have bonding,
if you've got two wave
functions that overlap and they
have opposite signs,
you're going to have
destructive interference,
and you're not going to have
bonding.
So that will become important
later on in the course.
But now, as I started to point
out as I went through here,
what we've got are nodal
planes.
We've got planes here in which
there is no probability density
because there is no wave
function.
And nodal planes are a
consequence of angular nodes.
Angular nodes are values of
theta and phi that will make the
wave function be equal to zero.
So a radial node is a value of
r that makes the wave function
be zero; angular nodes are
values of theta and phi that
make the wave function be equal
to zero.
And the consequence of an
angular node is that you have an
angular plane.
That you have a nodal plane.
For example,
in the case of the pz wave
function, when theta is equal to
90, that makes the wave function
be zero.
And theta equal to 90
corresponds to everywhere on
this x,y-plane.
In the case of the px,
when phi is equal to 90,
if you plug it into your px
wave function,
you will find that you'll get
zero.
And when phi is equal to 90,
that means everywhere on the
y,z-plane, you have zero wave
function.
And the same thing here for the
py wave function,
phi is equal to zero.
That means everywhere on the
x,z-plane you have the wave
function be equal to zero.
So these nodal planes,
the angular nodes are
consequences of values of theta
and phi that make the wave
function be zero.
All right.
In general, and this is
something you really do have to
know, the total number of nodes
that a wave function has is
always n minus 1.
It is given
by the principle quantum number
minus 1.
The number of angular nodes is
always given by the angular
momentum quantum number l.
If l is equal to 1,
you have a p wave function,
you've got one angular node.
And so, therefore,
if l is the number of angular
nodes and n minus 1 is the
number of total nodes,
and you only have angular and
radial nodes,
then n minus 1 minus l is the
number of radial nodes.
So the only thing you have to
remember is l always gives you
the number of angular nodes,
and you have to remember n
minus 1 is the number of total
nodes, and then you can always
just figure out that n minus 1
minus l is the number of radial
nodes.
For example,
here, 2p orbital,
number of total nodes 1,
number of angular nodes 1,
number of radial nodes 0.
You've got to know this.
And the other thing you have to
know is you have to be able to
go the other way around.
In other words,
if I tell you a wave function
has so many angular nodes and so
many radial nodes,
tell me what the possible wave
functions are.
So you've got to be able to go
both ways on this.
We've looked at kind of the
shapes of these p wave functions
by looking at the probability
densities, but there is another
aspect of these p wave functions
that I want to look at.
And that is that I want to look
at their radial probabilities.
I want to look at the radial
probability distributions for
the p wave functions.
And compare those to the s wave
functions.
And so I've plotted here the
radial probability for the 2s.
We just looked at that.
And I plotted here the radial
probability for the 2p wave
function.
Again, the radial probability
here at r is equal to 0 is zero.
And for the 2p wave function,
you can see that there is no
other radial node.
A 2p wave function doesn't have
a radial node.
You can see that reflected in
the radial probability
distribution.
But the point I want to make
right here is this.
That the most probable value of
r for an electron in the 2p
state is actually a little
closer in than the most probable
value of r for the 2s state.
As the angular momentum quantum
number goes up,
on the average the electrons
are a little bit closer in to
the nucleus, on the average.
Here is the radial probability
for 3s that we looked at.
You can see the two radial
nodes here, one here,
one here, r equals 0 is not a
radial node.
Here is the radial probability
for the 3p state.
You can see in 3p,
we've got one radial node right
in here.
This is not a radial node.
And here is the 3d state.
We didn't look at the
probability density for 3d.
You will look at that with
Professor Drennan in the second
half of the course when we talk
about transition metals.
But here you don't see any
radial nodes.
You see an r equals 0,
but that is because of our
definition for the radial
probability distribution.
Again, the point I want to make
is here is the most probable
value of r for 3s.
Here it is for 3p.
Here it is for 3d.
Again, the most probable value
of r for 3d is a little smaller
than it is for 3p,
is a smaller than it is for 3s.
In general, the angular
momentum quantum number goes up.
The electrons are a little bit
closer into the nucleus.
However, and this is important,
only in the s-orbitals or the s
states is there really a
substantial probability of being
very close to the nucleus.
Because, look,
it's only in the 3s or the 2s
do you have really some
probability that is very,
very close to the nucleus.
You don't have that in 3p or 3d
or 2p.
So there is kind of a irony
here.
It's only in the s states that
you have a considerable
probability of being really
close to the nucleus.
But in general,
as you increase the angular
momentum quantum number,
the most probable value of r
comes in closer to the nucleus.
So we've got two competing
factors there.
Now, this information on this
slide here might seem to you
kind of like it's unattached,
and why is she telling me this.
And I understand that that's
probably how you feel at the
moment, but I have to tell it to
you now, because next time we're
going to use this information to
understand the behavior of
atoms.
This information is going to be
important.
We're going to refer back to it
in the next few lectures.
We're done at the moment for
what we're going to say about
the hydrogen atom.
And now it's time to move on to
multi-electron atoms.
And we're going to start here
with helium.
Well, the Schrödinger equation,
of course, correctly predicts
the atomic structure of all
atoms.
But the difficulty is that as
you increase the number of
electrons, the problem,
the differential equation that
you have to solve,
gets more and more complicated.
And there is no nice analytical
way to solve that equation,
which means that there is not
going to be a nice analytical
form, for example,
for the allowed energies for a
helium atom.
That is, we're not going to get
an expression of E sub n equal
to minus R sub H over n squared.
This is a nice analytical
expression for the hydrogen atom
energies.
We're not going to get that for
helium.
So if you solve the equation
for helium, what you actually
have to do numerically,
what you're going to get is a
list of numbers and you're not
going to get a nice analytical
form for the wave function.
What you're going to get is the
amplitude of the function as a
function of r,
theta and phi,
another list of numbers.
But the truth is,
as you increase the number of
electrons in the system,
you very quickly,
by the time you get to three
and four, run into such a
problem that you cannot even
solve the Schrödinger equation
exactly, even numerically.
Why?
Well, here is the example.
Here is helium.
Here is the Schrödinger
equation for helium.
I didn't write out the
Hamiltonian precisely.
I just wrote the general
Hamiltonian.
But what I want you to see is
that the true wave function for
the helium atom would be a wave
function that had six
coordinates in it.
Two values of r for each one of
the electrons,
electron 1, electron 2.
Two values of theta.
Two values of phi.
We already have six coordinates
in that wave function in the
case of helium.
And as we go to lithium,
beryllium, boron,
the number of electrons,
these wave functions,
the number of coordinates,
it just goes up exponentially.
And so in order to solve this
equation, we're going to need
some approximations.
And we're going to talk about
the most basic approximation
that there is.
And that is called the
one-electron wave approximation
or the one-electron orbital
approximation.
And here is the essence of that
What we're going to do is we're
going to take that wave function
and we're going to assume that
that wave function can be
factored into a wave function
for electron one times a wave
function for electron two.
So it's a one electron wave.
Each electron gets its own wave
in this approximation.
We're going to make a further
approximation.
And that is that we're going to
give the functional form to
electron one in the helium atom.
We're going to give it a
functional form that looks like
that of an electron in hydrogen.
We're going to give it the
psi(1,0,0) wave function.
Same thing for electron number
two, or an alternate way to
write that is 1s 1 times 1s 2
where this refers
to electron one,
this refers to electron two.
And a more shorthand way is to
write this as 1s 2,
1s squared.
So that's the
approximation for helium.
Let's just carry it out for
lithium.
Well, here is what the wave
function would really look like,
the function of nine variables.
But we're going to give each
electron its own wave function
in this approximation.
And, again, we're going to say
electron one has the 1s hydrogen
wave function and electron two
has the 1s hydrogen wave
function, and electron three has
the 2s hydrogen wave function.
Another way to write that is 1s
2 2s.
Do you have a question over
here?
Can I help you?
Okay.
How about beryllium?
16.
But we're going to use our
approximation again.
One electron is 1s 1s 2s 2s.
The way to write that is 1s 2
2s 2.
And we can keep going.
And when I keep going,
you go, oh, I've seen this
before.
You've written down the
electron configurations for all
of the atoms in the periodic
table.
Here they are.
Do you know what those electron
configurations were that you
wrote down?
They were just the shorthand
notation for the one-electron
wave function approximation to
solve the Schrödinger's
equation.
That what those were.
That's it.
Nothing more.
But now what you do notice is
that when I got to boron here,
I didn't give all five
electrons the 1s hydrogen wave
function.
And when I got to carbon,
I didn't give all six electrons
the 1s hydrogen wave function.
Why didn't I do that?
Well, you already know that
there is something called
"spin." And you already know
that in the 1s state,
you can only put in two
electrons, and one of those
electrons has to be spin up and
one has to be spin down.
And the same thing for all of
these other states,
one has to be spin up and one
has to be spin down.
Here is the electron
configuration here for neon.
That electron configuration
just being the shorthand
notation for the wave function
in the one-electron orbital
approximation.
Now we've got to talk about
spin.
What is this thing called spin?
Well, spin is entirely a
quantum mechanical phenomenon.
It has no classical analogy
that is accurate,
that is correct.
Spin is intrinsic angular
momentum.
It is angular momentum that is
built into your particle.
It's part of the nature of the
particle.
Electrons have spin.
How do you see the spin?
Well, if you solve the
relativistic Schrödinger's
equation, which we didn't even
write down, if you solve that
equation, as drafted,
well, then one other quantum
number drops out,
and that is the spin quantum
number.
And that spin quantum number we
call m sub s.
And m sub s has two allowed
values.
It can be one half or it can be
minus one half.
So here we have a quantum
number that is not an integer.
It's one half or minus one
half.
Now, what students often like
to do is to think about spin as
a classical analogy whereby if
you have some electrons,
so this is my electron here,
and it is spinning around its
own axis, the angular momentum
vectum is perpendicular to that
plane.
And if it is spinning in this
direction, you might call this
spin up.
But, of course,
if it's spinning in the other
direction, and then the angular
momentum vector is again
perpendicular to that plane,
you might call that spin down.
This is a classical analogy
that is not correct.
The electron is not rotating
around its own axis.
But if it's going to help you
think about that right now,
okay, just remember it's not
really correct because this idea
of spin is intrinsic angular
momentum.
It's part of the nature of the
particle itself.
Next time I will tell you about
Uhlenbeck and Goudsmit and
Pauli.
See you Wednesday.